so as we pick up with the house of
impart to what we learn is that Steve
Rogers is an old man now there is a
standalone story involving Steve Rogers
with the House of M storyline and in
that story we learned that he had
married Peggy Carter that he and Peggy
Carter had later got divorced that Bucky
Barnes had never died and so all these
events that had led to those that I
guess the position of captain or Steve
Rogers becoming Captain America and the
modern day had never happened and as we
know with the house of M this is a
reality that had been created by the
Scarlet Witch where everybody got their
hearts desires and this seems to be what
it was the Captain America wanted that
he wanted Peggy Carter's to I guess to
be married to her that he wanted Bucky
Barnes to stay alive but the sacrifice
that was made for all those things to
happen was that he could not be Captain
America in the modern time and so what
we do is we continue with this story is
that we pick up with Emma Frost and
Scott Summers and this is a very
interesting aspect of the house of M
because what it seems to be at least
what we're able to see going on here is
that Scott Summers and Emma Frost seem
to have some kind of a romantic
chemistry with one another they seem to
actually be dating in a serious
relationship we don't really know if
they're married or not but what we do
know is that they're they're
romantically involved what we also learn
here is that apparently Mary Jane Watson
is a major celebrity within the acting
scene which of course we knew that with
Mary Jane Watson her desire was to
become a very well known actress was
actually stepped into major roles in
Hollywood but what we do is we continue
on with this story is that we jump to
Los Angeles and we jump to Dazzler now
Dazzler is apparently I guess maybe a TV
show host of some kind on a TV show that
we're not really sure of but it seems to
be a TV show that belongs specifically
to her and what she's saying here is
that she's introducing Simon Williams to
maybe be part of the interviewer that
she's having her to be the main
attraction of her interview and again
what goes on here is that as Simon
Williams arrives the question that
Dazzler wants to know and the question
that everybody seems to want to know
given the fact this appears to be a
tabloid based TV show is that they want
to know what the relationship is between
Simon Williams and Carol Danvers and so
what we learn here is it again tying in
to Carol Danvers earth-616 counterpart
and the basis of the house of M Carol
Danvers is the most popular superhero in
America at the moment and this fits in
quite nicely with her s depiction in the
u.s. six one six continuity because
again if you had seen our videos on
Carol Danvers we had talked about how
she was always in search of identity and
so as we continue with Carol Danvers we
pick up with her as she is apparently
chasing roomie LeBeau she's chasing
gambit and another person most likely
roomies brother through through Los
Angeles and they're I guess their
attempts to commit some kind of a crime
here and so what happens is ultimately
she's successful in catching up with him
she's able to bring their vehicle to a
halt and she's able to take them into
custody dropping them off for the police
to pick up but what we do is we jump to
Cincinnati Ohio and we pick up with
Kitty Pryde and Kitty Pryde here is
actually a teacher in an instance in a t
Ohio she doesn't really seem to display
any abilities to us or the very least
she doesn't seem to display any powers
but again it most likely because of the
fact that this is the house of M and she
was a mutant in the earth-616 continuity
and she seems to be teaching mutants and
she does in fact have abilities and so
what she's doing is simply going about
teaching the children about the first
mutant and so on and she asked them who
the first meeting was and one of the
young girls replies and saying that the
first mutant was named with a submariner
which of course is true even in the
earth-616 continuity and when she asked
how it is this girl had known that so
she had actually read the reading like
she was supposed to you the girl simply
says no one says that her mother has a
fixation on on name of the Submariner
and so again Kitty Pryde going back to
teaching the children tells them about
how they're going to discuss named the
Submariner and some of the comments he
made during World War two that led to
this current society this is really just
her being depicted as a person who's
picking up the role of a continuing to
be a teacher for for this house of in
continuity much like she was in the
earth-616 continuity now what we do from
here is we jump to New York to Hell's
Kitchen and we pick up with a man who is
apparently trying to find or locate Luke
Cage which he successfully does and this
again is very interesting here because
Luke Cage seems to be some kind of a
underworld boss some kind of a a major
player within the realm of Hell's
Kitchen and so what happens is that this
person who's looking for her Luke Cage
is revealed to us to be Sam Wilson and
so what he does here is he begins
speaking with with
cage but Luke Cage is taunting him a
little bit in the sense that that it
appears as though as far as Luke Cage is
concerned that Sam Wilson is really the
token black employee for the New York
police force that they stuck him in
Hell's Kitchen because as they perceive
it because he's black he'd be able to
best relate to everybody in Hell's
Kitchen which as far as Luke Cage says
is that it isn't you know he asked the
question does it really make a Sam
Wilson feel a little bit used here but
again Sam Wilson seems to ignore these
giant as we would expect that he would
and he asked Luke aid if he knows
anything about about Wilson Fisk and
Luke Cage seems to play dumb here he
says he doesn't really know anything
about Wilson Fisk and he asked what it
is it had happened when Sam Wilson says
someone had beat Wilson Fisk into a coma
and so we asked Luke Cage where he was
and Luke eight says he was sleeping and
he asked whether yes Sam wasn't whether
or not he can still do the same and so
what we do is we jump from Hell's
Kitchen to the office of dr. strange who
apparently has a PhD in psychology and
is a psychologist and so what he's doing
here is he's I guess he's speaking with
or he's interviewing Robert Reynolds the
century and what he's basically trying
to get to is the idea of Robert Reynolds
- the basis behind these visions that
Robert Reynolds has here and what Robert
Reynolds says is that he had been
spending the day with his son and that
suddenly the blackness the black wall
had arrived and then the black wall had
just vanished out of nowhere and what
this does is tell us that even in this
house of M continuity that the void
still exists but this is really a
anomaly of sorts and the realm of the
House of M and the reason why is because
the void is the other half of Robert
Reynolds meaning that even if R Burt
Reynolds wish for the void to be gone
even if it was his heart's desire for
the void not to exist perhaps the
Scarlet Witch doesn't have enough power
to make sure the voids not there to
eliminate the void entirely which is
entirely possible considering how
powerful Robert Reynolds and the void
are or the other half of this equation
could simply be that it really is the
hearts desire of Robert Reynolds for the
void to exist because without the void
he's an incomplete person at this point
we don't really know here in fact we
really haven't delved into the
psychology of the void and Robert
Reynolds enough in Marvel Comics to know
if this is the case but again what we
see Doctor Strange doing is speaking
with Robert Reynolds and asking
him what happened to the wall that has
simply just disappear and Robert
Reynolds begins to question at the very
least even on a surface level his i
guess it's understanding in reality but
dr. strange simply asked him how that
makes him feel indicating to us that
he's again playing the role of a
psychologist here and so what we do is
we transition for a moment to Russia and
what we find here in Russia is at the
fields these I guess this vast amount of
farmland is being combed by by Colossus
indicating to us at the very least
Colossus exists in this reality that
because Charles Xavier had never formed
the x-men or at least we presumed so
that that the Charles Xavier had never
actually traveled to Russia to visit
Colossus and then - I guess bring him
into the x-men and so as a result
Colossus still just maintains his life
in Russia and so what we do is we pick
up with the final person of this story
and we join with Wolverine and Wolverine
here is apparently either experiencing
the Weapon X project or the very least
maybe dreaming about it and this is what
we learn we learn that he's actually
dreaming about the Weapon X project and
that once he emerges from this tank that
had given him as adamantium that he
suddenly snaps out of the stream that he
suddenly wakes up but when he wakes up
he seems to actually wake out to a Jean
gray indicating that maybe it was his
heart's desire that he and Jean Grey
were together and the Jean Grae be left
alive and so what had happened here is
that as Wolf rain begins to approach
Jean Grey as he begins to ask what's
going on that Jean Grey is revealed to
be mystique and that mystique says he
had some kind of a fetish for redheads
and what seems to be happening here with
Wolverine is unlike everybody else who
at the very least seems to just be okay
with this reality or has no idea of the
previous reality Wolverine is appearing
I guess it appears to be aware of what's
going on appears to be that things
aren't right here and so what he does is
he leaves the room with him and a
mystique and when he walks outside he
finds toad and what appears to be
Jessica drew and so as the two of them
are discussing they ask him whether he's
all right but he runs outside of the
building onto a balcony and when he
looks out he sees an entire Armada all
of these various ships and and I guess
helicarrier's and so on bearing the
insignia of magneto with that being said
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly
you